[Music]
in desperate for views news we are
submit by UC Irvine represent Oh
youtuber horrifies as viewers after
passionately kissing his sister video oh
my god I was just thinking about this
not morning dude well the only thing is
I won't have an answer for you because I
don't know what his is can you guys
write in the comment because I know you
guys will find it you guys are awesome
detective to me he looks like so this is
actually a really no I thought it was
either gonna be a white guy or rice gun
well what's the rice gun I think some
other guy but he does like a lot of
white people to share this is prank
invasion some of us know him from
YouTube he's been around the block he's
the guy that is known for running around
and getting girls to play a game for a
quick kiss Middle Eastern yeah he
doesn't wait so my reason why I said
white is because his sister looks like
she's white with something and that's
his sister good-looking they're [ __ ]
good-looking yeah well they super
good-looking oh that's them again oh
they changed they look like the dam's
family really look at me have colored
eyes or I lose contact but wait does he
know in the first photo it looks I guess
I blue eyes or something I mean you
could be middle features like the nose
is making poor porno fetish real Yeah
right
well Game of Thrones started it come on
me sorry this is like my favorite story
of the day because I'm like she's rockin
excited about this is strange siblings
and then they finally got to see each
other I will be cool that one is less
creepy and disgusting
I think someone that you grew up with
yes but they grew up together that's
what they well he says it's his
half-sister but in like it makes it
better it's kind of creepy he starts out
by like pacing around his house and he's
like all right guys I owe you guys
something big today like
probably describes it on the audience
like oh you guys something really big
today buddy said that it was like
account was hacked for three months it's
yeah he said all of his social media and
his YouTube channel had been hacked for
like three months so he wanted to come
in with a bang he was like I know you
guys been waiting for me to eat my mom's
so I'm gonna do this video what the [ __ ]
that's the same [ __ ] it's like what do
who's looking forward for that [ __ ] yeah
man I've been thinking you're an
inspiration I've been waiting for the
data you [ __ ] mac down with your
sister man people go you've been asking
I've been getting a lot of increase in
my DNS you guys have been asking for
this so here we go it's like knowing
like who I mean it's like nobody and
then it's like crazy so this guy's name
is Kris Munroe he's a pretty popular
youtuber a lot of you guys might know
him but there's there's some very
popular h3h3 beef with him dude that
shit's flawed Ethan's roasting the [ __ ]
out of his fool right now he said that
he owes his fans something big I think
the creepiest part of the video for me
you saw the video
yeah but the part before isn't in here
and all right he's like all right guys
yeah my sister knows I'm like a youtuber
or like a vlogger but like I'm so
nervous to go out there like how do I
initiate this and I mean okay I'm just
gonna go out there I'm just gonna go up
there and start talking to her and in so
he [ __ ] being protective slow kisses
his sister oh dude that's all the thumb
no I didn't want to click it bro look I
was like reading up on this story and I
haven't even seen this whole clip guess
what I'm not gonna watch it you guys are
you know what's the most disturbing part
why does it look hot it's like he like
kind of like forces her so she didn't
know at all like it was natural who
knows in these vlogs she was in on it
but he had to be in on it
just keep that concept and I want you
guys to be very very quick here we go
rock scissors why scissors oh it's a
challenge when look dude this is so what
if you win it's like what you you kiss
first on I don't get the knife so you
had a one
they wouldn't have done the kid like he
really wants it
oh he wants this cool thing you did it
over Oh No but why why engage fly again
way too comfortably don't watch Game of
Thrones so I'm like you're afraid of it
it's like a call interrupts it but then
look you bring their back in this is
weird and then oh dude that's good he
really want that disgusting cuz I don't
know anything about them it just looks
like two people kissing you know I'm
disgusted cuz I have a brother and I
can't I have only half of that thought
can never incept my mind yeah do I never
once wondered what like what would that
be my matter never in my mind I'm
thinking you're not siblings right right
that's of everyone things some people
call those Fiona no she really is my
half-sister like he was like her like
fighting to prove it to people he's like
guys here's an old photo of us you know
from before like we grew up together and
it's like bro yo chill we're trying to
protect him and he's like don't protect
me here's a video of me [ __ ] my
sister yeah like this is the type of
dude that would like go into the room
and like our guys I'm really gonna do it
shut the door and you hear like moaning
for a YouTube video like that's that's
literally some [ __ ] he would do and for
me it's like whether this she has a
sister or not a sister it's just how
much
thirst is oozing out of him
like the chemistry in the room their
forehead hey what's up guys so like you
guys been asking for this what the [ __ ]
is wrong with this guy why's this guy
all like this all of a sudden he's like
I got a [ __ ] 12-inch [ __ ] I got
something
it's so weird wait also guys the title
of this video is kissing my actual
sister prank how is that a prank he's
using that next we're getting pranked
and he's like okay not my sister please
let that be it look at the end though
dynamic in the room is weird
you guys are so romantic they were
wanting this for a long time they love
each other why do you hate love well how
could it be more closer than loving your
sibling and then you love your you love
them in many ways I don't know I think
it's [ __ ] disgusting this is crazy so
this is not Chris's first like rodeo and
doing some weird [ __ ] he's had beef with
even climbed from each tree for like
years now of course you know I love the
teeth so Ethan would do a couple videos
on him and then like he would always try
and fight back and it was at first he
thought it was getting on publicity but
then he just realized it was burying him
because like this is a joke right so
Chris prank invasion he like he just
can't give up bro he could not give up
so he comes back in and he decided to
challenge Ethan to a fight I challenged
h3h3 productions my region member to a
fight if I lose I delete my YouTube
channels and I give him $100,000 oh that
sounds fair but I mean we all know that
Chris is just fishing for publicity he
wants to be able to say that he box even
Klein
getting your ass beat by ethan klein is
like like that's that's like an
accomplishment you know like her just
being in the ring you know that's he
just wants like a little bit of clout so
Ethan responded and he said
even responded how about a quick game
for a quick kiss instead hey I think
this one was a little over a year ago
but it just kind of gives you some
backstory into like how seriously Chris
takes this and he's like trying to milk
it and Ethan's just like yeah then how
better quick kids know he's not on his
level he's yeah I'm not even gonna
respond to your ass so I guess so Easter
Egg roasted him again in his podcast
like later on about this whole kissing
the thing because there's a lot of
youtubers doing like reaction videos all
that right now so then ding ding right
this comes back in and he says hey h3h3
productions you declined a boxing match
with me fair enough you're not stupid
how about a chess match for $100,000
you're much smarter so it should be easy
money right where do you go to college
again he basically thinks that he's
really smart he keeps like boasting
around college and I think that parted
Ethan's model is like he's he's very
intellectual like he's a smart guy so
chris is trying to say like okay you
don't want to fight how about chess I'm
smarter than you and like I knew I don't
think that he really cared about winning
or losing a boxing match but I think
that he really did want to come in hot
and claim that he won against like even
a soul thirsty the way in so there's a
regular social interaction with people
yeah I think that his first attempt was
like it's almost like the the dude
that's like [ __ ] me your muscles
touches muscles but he's a [ __ ] creep
right and then is that all you don't
[ __ ] date this this is my college
degree you one date me now but he's
missing the point thirst literally clout
thirst so of course Ethan is no Khalid
so he has to do all this [ __ ] to get
babe SCD change
one-liners like this is avatar this guy
yeah so this is Chris's response he goes
reread my statement your reply as a
logical fail I would know because I
scored it one cent before on the asset
got me into northwestern law after
graduating with top honors from UC
Berkeley by the way doesn't get it you
just keep pulling out all these smart
guy is pretty dense yeah like and the
funny thing is is like after two years
of like Ethan literally just beating his
ass on anything like he's still taking
it personally
this isn't good like it's like he tried
to like turn around and like be like
yeah I'm gonna mean with you two men
yeah I mean I'm gonna play along and
then he's like this hurts yeah like
that's literally what's happening well I
mean for a guy that's kissing his sister
for [ __ ] two views I don't know how
he takes himself so serious that means
the rock-paper-scissors in the beginning
I like what does that do I kiss you like
game for a quick cut I don't it's like
he couldn't wait to like like like the
kiss it was like well we're just gonna
pretend it doesn't matter if I win or
lose it's almost like yeah that means we
gotta [ __ ] yeah like it's like oh she
won well you get to kiss me yeah either
this gusty winds that's weird
[Music]
[Music]